a lot of us know that you like a lot of
weird stuff I'm just curious what's the
weirdest thing we've ever seen
ever seen other than him going Knuckles
deep in some random dude's belly button
we were uh we were in Australia and New
Zealand in January oh this was maybe one
of the weirder things yeah um and we
were in a I mean green line and this
dude came up and he first words out of
his mouth were do you guys want to see
something weird
and by the way in my
I should know better and both of us kind
of like very timidly said yes and he
unzipped his jeans
whatever comes out you are confident
enough to walk up like that I got to be
man enough to take a look see what I'm
saying yeah and he walks up and he owns
his pants and he reaches in and he pulls
out a tarantula the size large spider
tooth
furry handed spider and we were both
confused and we were like so why why why
why do you do that and his response was
it likes to go for the ride
no the it doesn't you like the
feeling of weird eight weird hairy
fingers around your nut sack dude that's
creepy
like by the way when you say it like
that it doesn't sound terrible
it's pretty much two hands are just
missing the thumbs like yes
it's like a cradle for your nutsacking
yes I don't know that actually doesn't
sound I mean other than the things no
all of it sounds bad why am I reasoning
with this I'm gonna I'm gonna be honest
with you I don't remember how we got on
this topic so